-2 < x < -1.
So, x is between -2 and -1.
This is an and
inequality written without the word.
When solving this type of compound
inequality, you must add,
subtract, multiply, or divide to all
three parts of the compound inequality.
The easiest way to do this is
to break it up into two parts.
Let's do this part first.
So here we have the regular inequality
5 < 2x + 3 times the quantity x + 5.
We'll solve this the way we normally do
with it, just a regular linear equation.
So the 3 gets distributed to the x and
to the 5 and we get 5 < 2x + 3x + 15.
To simplify it, we get 5 < 5X + 15,
subtract 15 from both sides and
we get -10 < 5X.
To isolate x, we should get rid of
the 5 so divided by 5 on both sides.
And we're left with -2 < x.
All right, so
we have one half of the inequality.
Next, we should just take
a look at the right side.
So we have 2x + 3(x + 5) < 10.
Again we distribute the 3 to the x and
to the 5, and we get the same thing.
2x + 3x + 15 < 10.
Simplify a bit to get 5x + 15 < 10,
subtract 15 from both sides.
And we get 5x is less than -5.
We divide by 5 on both sides,
and we're left with x < -1.
So -2 < x, and x < -1.
So x is between -2 and -1.
So let's draw this on our number line.
And -2 is less than x is
another way to say x > -2.
So on the number line our arrow will
point towards positive infinity.
And for x < -1, find -1 here and
our line should point
towards negative infinity.
This is where the two lines overlap.
This is our solution set and
it's true x really is between -2 and -1.